i have to question you about this
because you used to make fun of star
wars
you would go out of your way to make fun
of star wars you didn't yes you did no i
didn't
i only did it when it came out and i saw
a long line of people looking like they
were going to enjoy themselves
and i did my comedy job was i made fun
of them and i tried to make them feel
stupid
i do that all the time that is the job
of a comedian so it had nothing to do
with star wars made fun of steve jobs
when he died and all the nerds that
loved his little big little big little
[ __ ] that he did on computers
yeah i made fun of it yeah so what you
do is when you see
people enjoying themselves or filled
with any kind of glee anticipation of a
wonderful day
what do you like to do you like to take
that away i come in in my x-win
fighter to get into your world and i i i
say my world
i did not
i like the original lost in space you
know that's that was my thing with
i loved it he just couldn't he couldn't
hold his composure no who knew
just like anything that was happening
but i loved when [ __ ] wasn't happening
he would he could be sit in the calmness
of being lost in space with the
spaceship that
did the spaceship work yeah it works
they would go from planet to planet but
they were lost
but i'm talking about the island in
space the 1960s lost in space they had
this ridiculous uh character
dr smith loved him who said you
bubble-headed booby
and uh he would yell at the robot all
the time and every episode
he would take the kids and try to sell
them to aliens
so that they could be taken off to an
intergalactic zoo the parents would foil
it at the last second
literally try and take their children
from him and his punishment at the end
would be like
no blueberry pie for you dr smith and
he'd go
whomp womp what he tried to kill your
children it was an abuse
he didn't he tried to leave him behind
uh yeah yeah awful guy
no one's going to care about this part
check it out 60 is lost
in space it's just absolutely
fascinating
it's an abusive relationship yeah right
he's lonely
he didn't have a partner out there no
his partner was a robot
maybe he felt like if he got rid of some
of the stuff that these people loved
that he had a shot at luff that's a very
good
read on it i'm just saying i think he
has compassion
for dr smith but not for anybody else
yeah
star wars you dr smith child killer
maybe you should think of it from this
time
yeah it's you know you're all over the
map you're all over the map
you know i don't think i am i think i'm
right on it
but that's congratulations that's how
human beings are
everything i'm saying totally makes
sense to me right
i mean if you could if you could hear
the applause between my ear right
no now i no i know i'm an idiot i know
i'm an idiot
yeah and i should have read a lot more
in life and i didn't there's
there's still time